non
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous trouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de parlement
hebdo 30 minutes pour refaire
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
bonjour katia bonjour michael et cette
semaine nous accueillons marie noëlle
lienemann bonjour vous êtes vice
présidente du sénat sénatrice socialiste
de paris marie noëlle lienemann on va
dérouler avec vous le film de la semaine
l'abandon du projet d'aéroport à notre
dame des landes apaisement renoncement
la décision du gouvernement a suscité
moult réactions
le président du sénat était en visite à
l'assemblée gérard larcher est venu voir
les députés les républicains pour
évoquer l'épineux dossier de la révision
constitutionnelle et puis on va parler
marie noëlle lienemann de votre
formation entre ceux qui sont candidats
à la tête du ps qu est ce qui quitte le
parti et la vie politique comme didier
guillaume président du groupe socialiste
au sénat
ben va ouvrir cette émission avec
l'annoncé cette semaine celle de notre
dame des landes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a bordeaux donc de l'aéroport de notre
dame des landes le sujet a occupé la
séance des questions d'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
était interrogé
pas moins de cinq reprise soutenue par
les armes est aussi très critiqué par
notamment les républicains regardez ce
reportage
il désignait maïté frémont au centre des
questions au gouvernement l'abandon du
projet d'aéroport de notre dame des
landes
edouard philippe est interrogé par
plusieurs députés sur sa décision
la question la plus virulente celle de
marc le fur
l'élu des républicains notamment accusé
paris d'abandonner les bretons en rase
campagne
vous avez décidé de jeter l'épongé vous
abandonner un projet qui touché au but
la déclaration d'utilité publique elle
est de 2013
arrêtons d'évoquer 50 ans 40 ans
c'est il ya cinq ans une décision
pourtant irrévocable pour edouard
chilien depuis 2012
il n'a pas été possible de faire
prévaloir la loi je pense monsieur le
député est en vérité je le sais que cela
aussi vous agace
eh bien je veux faire entrer ce projet
dans le droit je veux faire en sorte que
nous puissions penser mobilité et
développement du grand ouest
autrement sur les bancs du modem mais
également du côté de la france hors is
on salue la décision
vous avez donc rejoint monsieur le
premier ministre le camp déraisonnable
avec le groupe b la france insoumise
nous espérons que vous y resterez au
moins un instant je crains madame la
députée de devoir vous dire que si j'ai
pris la décision que je viens d'annoncer
je ne l'ait pas fait pour vous faire
plaisir
durant cette séance de questions au
gouvernement le premier ministre est
intervenu à cinq reprises sur le sujet
edouard philippe a reçu une standing
ovation de la part des députés de la
majorité
manuel valls ce vendredi que la bande ou
d'aéroport de notre dame des landes est
une mauvaise chose et vous écoutez moi
sur ce sujet je n'ai jamais réussi à me
faire clairement une idée pour savoir si
j'étais franchement pour ou franchement
contre je ne crois pas qu'on puisse
caricaturer les positions il ya des
arguments économiques et
environnementaux pour notre dame des
landes et y en avait des choses sur le
fond en plus j'avais pas besoin de
décider
je me suis doit pas amener à s'est en
revanche en revanche je crois quand même
que on ne peut pas considérer que c'est
anodin de prendre une décision contre
l'avis de tous les élus en tout cas de
la grande majorité des élus concernés de
prendre une décision après un référendum
dont on peut peut-être contester le
contour mais qui a eu lieu
moi j'ai toujours dit sur ce sujet que
seuls à nouveau référendum pouvait être
de nature à invalider le vote du
suffrage universel
alors maintenant la décision est prise
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que y'a pas que sur ce sujet où je vois
les choix des manuels macron et de
jeunes et douars philippe glisse est
loin de l'idée de régénérer une
démocratie représentative mais plutôt de
la contourner c'est tout le débat sur
les corps intermédiaires c'est tout le
débat sur les élus alors je pense pour
l'instant que donc il s'agit pas
simplement de ronger son frein parce
qu'il y avait aussi des arguments qui
pouvait légitimer ce vote ce choix et je
pense que ce qui est urgent maintenant
c'est de se dire comment on décide pour
ses grandes infrastructures mais pour
qu'on est d'abord un choix stratégique
puis un choix de où et comment la maire
socialiste de nantes a parlé d'un déni
de démocratie c'est fort comme d'accord
avec elle
elle est maire de nantes sur donc là
j'ai beaucoup de voix qui dit moi je dis
qu'il ya une crise et non il ne règle
pas le problème de la crise démocratique
et la méthode utilisée est de nature à
plutôt fragiliser la démocratie
représentative qui est aujourd'hui en
crise néanmoins là que des mots collard
la démocratie représentative
on ne suffit pas de la maintenir tel
quel si on n'est pas capable de donner
plus de légitimité par des méthodes qui
font que les citoyens sont associés qui
a une clarté de qui décide et coop ce
point exemple les référendum et il est
contesté sur le périmètre
il faut maintenant dans la loi quand il
ya référendum sur l'infrastructure on
dise clairement comment s'établit le
champ de référendaire parce que on ne
peut pas vivre avec des référendums dont
ils sont contestés dès que le vote a
atteint parce que c'est pas ce qu'on
voulait voilà je pense que là il ya des
grands des craintes de son intérêt
dernière chose que je voudrais dire
c'est que de toute façon le gouvernement
dit on agit quelque part il n'est pas
trop le choix puisque je vous rappelle
que la des uv tomber à la fin du mois de
janvier nation intitulé oui donc sous
contrainte décision sous contrainte non
mais je veux dire par là de nous faire
une sauce et il fallait décider à il
fallait décider
et dernière chose et comment on arrive à
des telles lenteur et là il ya un
problème avec la justice aussi parce
qu'il ya eu tant de routes ou de gagner
mais très longue
donc voilà alors ce jeudi marie noëlle
lienemann emmanuel macron et theresa may
ont passé un autre sujet ont signé un
nouveau traité sur le contrôle de
l'immigration entre la france et le
royaume est né à sundance près de
londres
il s'agit d'améliorer la gestion des
migrants à la frontière commune et
notamment le traitement des mineurs non
accompagnés qui sont demandeurs d'asile
est ce que vous pensez qu emmanuel
macron est en position de force face à
la chef du gouvernement britannique qui
a tendance à faire primer un peu la
volonté des britanniques qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
non je crois qu'il s'est pas mis en
situation de l'amour de force moi je
regrette fondamentalement ce traité
parce que je crois que la france ne peut
pas valider durablement
l'idée que la frontière se fait à calais
et pas à douvres il faut que la
frontière à 12 oui absolument d'ailleurs
j'observe que
ce que disait emmanuel macron quand il
était ministre l'économie des finances
et l'exercice du pouvoir que bien
peut-être changer d'avis oui alors c'est
facile quand il dit j'ai fait j'ai fait
ce que j'ai promis c'est parce qu'il est
fidèle à ses convictions
et quand il change d'avis et simplement
cause de la de l'exercice du robusta
casse tête que j'attendais mais oui mais
c'est un casse tête c'est là on est en
train de continuer on valide en faisant
un nouveau traité ou on dit pourquoi on
nous demande 50 millions plus un
raccourcissement 50 millions d'euros
c'est ce que donne l'ongle et s'est
passé là bas non seulement ça change
rien mais ça fixe dans le marbre
ça fait encore un délai supplémentaire
pour poser la question centrale de où
est la frontière car moi je le dis tout
net c'est quand même pas normal fusent
même si on nous paye que ce soit quand
même en france que nous ayons les
conséquences du refus des angles est une
diva raccourcir les délais pour les
mineurs très bien mais sauf que il y en
a plein qui ne sont pas reconnu même
quand ils ont de la famille en grande
bretagne la grande bretagne est très
malthusienne sur ce sujet qui doit après
assumer cette difficulté les conseils
généraux l'état français air france
rennes et en harmonie dans les britten
les bases c'est-à-dire la france ne veut
pas résister ne veut pas imposer un
rapport de force avec les bonus qu'on ne
veut pas imposer le rapport de forces
c'est ce que vous dites c'est la france
et l'appui le même
vous avez le même problème sur la
réorientation de l'union européenne la
thèse de d'emmanuel macron c'est quand
on sera le bon élève dans le cadre
existant pour essayer de modifier la
réalité c'est que ce n'est pas ça qui
s'opèrent à limone autre dossier cette
semaine la réforme constitutionnelle
elle est lancée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lequel les négociations ont commencé un
petit peu en avance emmanuel macron
voudrais essayer de le faire avant l'été
l'assemblée a fait des propositions le
président du sénat lui aussi fera des
propositions le 24 mars président du
sénat qui était devant le groupe
républicain à l'assemblée nationale
stéphanie des pierres vous raconte tout
cela c'est une première gérard larcher
le président du sénat a fait le
déplacement jusqu'à l'assemblée sur les
terres de françois de rugy
il vient rencontrer ses collègues
députés du groupe l'est républicain et
laurent wauquiez le chef du parti
une manière pour gérard larcher de
montrer qu'il est incontournable dans
les négociations sur la révision
constitutionnelle devant les députés le
président du sénat a rappelé ses lignes
rouges
gérard larcher a rappelé qu'ils étaient
opposés la limitation du cumul des
mandats dans le temps mais que dans le
même temps était favorable à la
réduction du nombre de députés ce qui
est le cas aussi pour le groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale il a
rappelé qu'il fallait garder ce lien
avec les territoires il a rappelé que le
droit d'amendement est un droit
individuel et qu'il fallait respecter
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat comme
des lieux de débat est donc pas d'avoir
forcément des procédures accélérées
permanente donc 100 tonnes de choses il
ya eu beaucoup de points de convergence
convergence donc entre gérard larcher et
les élus les républicains même si sur la
proportionnelle les députés sont plus
vindicatif s'agit selon la propre c'est
le président république s'est engagé
c'est engagements qu'il a pris devant
les français donc on ne peut pas
évidemment lui demander de renoncer cet
engagement maintenant tout dépend de la
dose de proportionnelle
il faut qu'elle soit la plus réduite
possible pour éviter justement d'avoir a
créé par ailleurs des cires conception
immense et a coupé les parlementaires du
terrain les négociations entre l'elysée
et les deux chambres entre la majorité
et les autres partis ne font que
commencer
vous êtes prêt vice-présidente du sénat
gérard larcher
c'est l'homme clé de cette réforme
constitutionnelle c'est lui qui tire les
pouvoirs du oui ou du non si les
sénateurs et les députés
c'est lui qui négocie bien sûr et
négocie d'ailleurs une commission qui
est constituée au sénat pour sur ces
sujets il négocie pâques ou non des
rares marchés et bien sûr par rapport à
la majorité au sénat et une majorité de
droite tendance les républiques et vous
lui faites confiance aujourd'hui vous
lui dites au président du sénat rails
il a le droit au nom des sénateurs
d'aller dire oui ou de dire non sur
cette surface en il n'y aura pas à dire
we want faudra voter un moment donné
donc ce qui se joue aujourd'hui dans les
discussions entre l'assemblée et le
sénat
c'est les capacités pour emmanuel macron
d'avoir trois cinquièmes des votes et le
président du sénat comme celui de
l'assemblée d'avoir une certaine
estimation de ce qui est possible de
passer mais moi je voudrais aller au
delà
je dis à quoi sert cette réforme
constitutionnelle et deuxièmement est-ce
qu'elle cible bien les vrais enjeux de
la crise que nous connaissons de nos
institutions
c'est ma réponse est non je vous donne
un exemple il ya un débat sain
proportionnelle mais la proportionnelle
c'est pas dans la constitution dans la
concession n'a pas besoin de changer la
constitution
deuxièmement on a par exemple le nombre
des députés le nom des députés c'est le
maximum
rien n'empêche qu'ils aient moins de
député ou de sénateur
le truc et on fixe un maximum donc de
toutes façons par rapport aux grandes
décisions à prendre n'y a pas besoin de
ce choix constitutionnels et moi je ne
validerai pas un système 1 qui consolide
la vème république
à un moment où je pense qu'il ya une
crise du poids du parlement et que ce
sujet n'ait absolument jamais posée et
j'aimerais bien que et gérard larcher
est françois de rugy m'en pose ces
questions je vais terminer la deuxième
chose moi à titre personnel je ne sais
pas ce que fera le parti socialiste je
suis contre la baisse du nombre d'élus
parce que ça ramène à ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
est ce que la france a trop d'élus ou
est ce que c'est que les politiques qui
est la représentation nationale n'a pas
assez de pouvoir la base de cette
réforme votre rencontre et je voudrais
que notre lit qu'il avait décidé de
votre très content même si c'est pas
peut-être pas le
le groupe en entier ou parti socialiste
votre attention pour l'instant c'est le
parti cdu ciolos des disciplines
oui mais attendez je suis pas en train
d'essayer de limiter la discipline de
côte on va voir un congrès on va avoir
une nouvelle direction parti socialiste
va faire bouger quand vous vous tenez
militants mais moi je dirais je ne peux
pas accepter que le coeur de gravité sur
la mise en cause du nombre d'élus alors
je suis autant que dans les petits
territoires
c'est facile d'aller après ils sont déjà
bien abandonné où il ya beaucoup de
députés qui pensent comme vous avant
d'en venir à la révision
constitutionnelle il faut que députés et
sénateurs qui sont sur un pied d'égalité
votent un même texte est ce que vous
pensez qu'il peut y avoir un accord
françois de rugy a l'air assez confiant
entre l'assemblée et le sénat sur un
texte commun je n'en sais rien je ne
peux pas vous dire aujourd'hui je sais
que le sénat est très divisée je sais
que l'assemblée n'est pas aussi
favorable à ça ce pas parce que fillon
avait dit que valider diminuer le nombre
d'élus c'est sale et de toutes les
crises économiques et sociales il rouge
le choeur oui non mais c'est gris parce
que la ligne n'est pas simplement défend
cible c'est que c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est à quoi sert le parlement
à quoi servent les élus on ne répond
comment les citoyens peuvent entrer dans
le jeu de la de la démocratie
représentative
samcon minent cette route par exemple
moi je suis favorable à ce qu'on étende
le référendum
je suis favorable à ce que le référendum
d'initiative populaire sont pas bouclées
comme il l'est actuellement
je suis favorable pour que sur le fait
qu'ils aient plus de recours que plus de
consultation préalable des citoyens
voilà il ya des éléments que l'assemblée
soit l'initiative des lois soit ne soit
pas par cette vème république
alors on va laisser la constitution de
côté on va parler d'une démission qui a
fait grand bruit au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
didier guillaume ne sera plus président
du groupe socialiste au sénat il a
décidé de quitter tout simplement la vie
politique
écoutez c'est un choix mûrement réfléchi
ça fait quelques semaines que j ai que
j'y pense et voilà j'étais très heureux
de cet engagement politique depuis tant
d'années très heureux d'avoir été du
local mer caen 6 général président du
département sénateurs ici même au sénat
je me suis vraiment éclaté c'était
formidable comme premier vice président
comme président de groupe j'ai vécu des
moments des moments vraiment très beau
mais j'ai pensé qu'à un certain moment à
mon âge je devais je pouvais tourner la
page et faire autre chose un nouveau
challenge professionnel et c'est ce que
je vais tenter maintenant de faire
nouveau challenge professionnel pour
didier guillaume cette annonce a suscité
beaucoup de réactions comme nous le
montre ce reportage de marie brémaud
c'est via son compte facebook dans la
matinée que didier guillaume a annoncé
son retrait de la vie politique
un message publié quelques minutes avant
le début de la réunion de groupe
socialiste hebdomadaire au sénat une
surprise pour la majorité des sénateurs
présents c'est une décision personnelle
qu'il a pris on peut le regretter parce
que c'est vrai que
venez de les lire il n'y a pas si
longtemps que ça bon après c'est sûr le
choix et ça lui appartient mais ce matin
l'heure était aux louanges aux idiomes a
fait son travail la drôme qu'au sénat
c'est un homme de conviction un homme de
gauche je suis pas toujours d'accord
avec lui je l'exprimé aussi mais je
salue encore une fois ses convictions
son travail depuis nombreuses années
pour ses concitoyens et pour notre parti
le sénateur de la drôme qui est
aujourd'hui une vie politique entamée
dans les années 1980 on était dans les
équipes de lionel jospin quelques
décennies et c'est un ami et cheveux je
lui reconnais maintenant cette capacité
à aller refaire une vie ailleurs
voilà bon vent à lui à 58 ans on le dit
partant dans le milieu du rugby
le nom de son successeur à la présidence
du groupe socialiste au sénat sera
connue mardi prochain la succession est
ouverte
wiki pour ce que vous même vous seriez
tenté pour heures non résidents ce
groupe
non mais il ya plusieurs candidats on
parle de notre ami kader on parle de
monsieur te définis laurence rossignol
et ce serait pas mal non plus qui est
des femmes dans les postes de présidente
attendez pour l'instant j'attends
d'avoir tous les candidats et candidates
et c'est ce qu'on dit voilà mais c'est
vrai que une certaine tendresse pour
laurence pourtant je ne suis pas
toujours d'accord avec elle mais je
pense qu'elle a envie aussi qu' on est
un ps et surtout un groupe qui soit
assez offensif assez en réflexion sur
les grandes mutations qui sont en cours
et en tenant nos fondamentaux
alors c'est l'heure de retrouver
maintenant notre partenaire du figaro
pointer pour parler de encore du parti
socialiste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour jean marie noëlle lienemann en
effet parler un peu du congrès ps vous
avez choisi votre candidat il s'agit
d'emmanuel morale qui représente un peu
les loups gauche du ps en tout cas une
opposition radicale à la politique d'
emmanuel macron cette ligne allait quand
même déjà occupé par benoît hamon jean
luc mélenchon il ya de la place pour
emmanuel morale pour la ce que nous
proposons avec emmanuel maurel s'est pas
simplement d'être l'ailé gauche du ps
nous proposons que le parti socialiste
s'engage une nouvelle synthèse avec un
pied d'appel qui soit claire 7ce pied
d'appel c'est de dire on n'est pas en
train de refaire le film de l'ancien
quinquennat tout le monde a bien vu que
c'est un échec
et donc il s'agit pas de repasser les
divisions c'est à dire aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que nous avons à proposer aux
français quel est l'avenir du mouvement
socialiste
premièrement c'est à venir il doit être
dans l'opposition emmanuel macron
d'abord parce que nous pensons qu'il ya
toujours un clivage gauche droite dans
ce pays et que 7,7 à l'heure de faire
croire qu'il est qu'il est évincé et le
leur c'est qu'en fait c'est pour faire
une politique de droite 2 jo fermes et
durs bien dit yves là parce que
définitive quand il ya un vote positif
des mots qui nous est proposé on va pas
se mettre à dire non quand on est
positif on a voté dès qu'on soit clair
mais la ligne claire clair mais juste
bien de synthèse c'est à dire la
deuxième chose c'est que on voit qu'une
crise du libéralisme
donc est ce que le parti socialiste qui
doit redonner du sens et moderniser ses
valeurs en les en les défendant en les
actualisant en leur donnant du contenu
par rapport aux défis d'aujourd'hui
est-ce que nous sommes libérés ou pas
nous nous disons clairement l'avenir du
parti socialiste et son présence d'être
anti libérale je te répudie exactement
aux logiques venons donc benoît hamon a
fait l'erreur
d'abord parce que nous voulons rester
aux participants et pas seulement
premièrement on verrait ce parti c'est
parce que nous ne croyons pas aux petits
partis
nous pensons que la gauche a besoin de
forces qui fédère et non pas seulement
de forme c'est un petit parti le labour
leur tour leur wii passe et par ailleurs
nous ne pensons pas qu'il faut
construire la vie politique sur la
présidentielle à une colle des tur moi
j'ai du respect pour benoît je pense que
ce qui fait la joie c'est son problème
de le voir moi mon choix il a toujours
été dire nous avons partie besoin de
parti qui fédère qui soit en symbiose
avec de larges pans je pense de la même
manière qu'avec jean luc mélenchon
autant nous sommes en opposition avec
emmanuel macron autant nous sommes en
challenge politique parce que la gauche
est plurielle dans ce pays et que nous
devons affirmer que l'accusation pour
vous de rejoindre le mouvement de benoît
hamon comme certains sinon je l'aurais
déjà fait un ces jeux considère que le
parti de l'avenir du parti socialiste
est pour moi important
martine aubry a apporté son soutien
jeudi à olivier faure est ce que vous
auriez aimé disposer de ce soutien à
l'époque de la fronde contre
françois hollande de hollande et
aubrystes et la lgo jupette vous étiez
entendu mais je ne pense plus on se pose
en question de la fronde ou pas la
fronde
la question c'est stop ou encore et
score par avec lui même avec les mêmes
habitudes on disait ou bien est ce qu'on
est capable de justement inventer une
nouvelle et m'a dit cela repart avec les
mêmes vous mettez dans le même panier
martine aubry et consorts
quand je ne dis pas qu'il faut pas que
martine existe dans le parti mais
j'observe que déjà au dernier congrès
elle avait soutenu jean christophe
cambadélis
elle nous avait dit vous avez tort
il faut que le parti on va réorienter la
politique de françois hollande on a vu
ce qu'il en était ça a été rien du tout
moi je dis au bout d'un moment je sais à
quoi politique est plus faible c'est ça
ouais c'est pas seulement mais c'est
qu'au bout d'un moment fait des accords
dans la confusion parce que il faut pas
faire de vagues parce que ceux-ci ou
parce que cela est bien au bout d'un
moment on en arrive à la monnaie une
dévitalisation moi je ne suis pas pour
la clarification au sens de coupe est
toujours les branches dire j'ai la
vérité c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je
suis pas pour les petits partis parce
que moi j'ai des convictions fortes mais
je sais qu'elles n'ont d'intérêt que
fédère dévitalisation en tout cas ya
quand même beaucoup de candidats on en
est à 5 peut-être si ce qu'on disait de
gaulle je ne crains pas le manque de
candidats après moi mais le surplus ça
tourne un peu à la course de petits
chevaux ce congrès ps est ce que si moi
je ne je pense qu'il faut pas commencer
à mépriser les gens parce que sous
prétexte qu'ils sont pas connues parce
que quand vous changez que tous les
grilles les leaders parts ou sur le
disqualifier forcément vous partez que
des gens nouveaux
ce que je veux dire c'est que le risque
est grand que ce soit autour de
personnes dont on voit mal le contour
politique alors qu'il faut que les
militants choisissent raisonnablement
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent être l'avenir
s'agit pas de trancher joue les 10 et
une feuille de route
moi je crois qu'il faut construire le
manifeste des socialites du socialisme
des temps nouveaux
mais ça veut dire qu'on croit encore
qu'on est socialiste qu'on n'ait pas
simplement un avatar de la social
démocratie européenne qui est dans une
crise profonde et qui a besoin d'un ps
français qui soit capable de projeter
cette idée républicaine qui a toujours
fait notre identité
on est profondément d'actualité l'ont un
peu des conditions du vote delphine
batho qui est candidate a dénoncé un
traficotage des statuts au profit d'une
petite mafia politique ce sont ces ses
mots et ce que je puis parce que
franchement mafia politique est-ce
qu'elle a besoin d'en contrôler tout
l'est tous les populismes qui a et
d'abord qu'elle vienne qu'elle dise je
suis pas d'accord et ses statuts vous
l'avez entendu au conseil national et
les membres de droit international
jamais le prend la parole et après il se
réveille par derrière en disant ça va
pas au bout d'un moment moi je me mets
en colère
elle cherche à exister je sais rien
petit tour de piste et route une en ce
sens du sage mais en solaire rien mais
moi s'il n'est pas d'accord mais qu'elle
le dise qu'on en débatte qu'elle
conteste qu'elle de qu'elles viennent
pour dire je ne vote pas et je donne à
courir j'ai la présentera sa motion je
pense j'ai l'impression qu'elle a des
difficultés à trouver des signataires et
qu' une des raisons pour lequel elle va
mettre en cause le statut dont je ne
sais pas si vous êtes approuvé par les
militants sont quand même soumis au vote
des militants
on va voir c'est de dire on m'empêche de
candidates pour sa part et sur le vote
on lui même certains comme luc carvounas
ont réclamé un vote électronique pour
nous que le vote soit pas entachée
d'irrégularités ce que vous craignez
salle et les irrégularités
chaque bonne il a d'abord je suis
content le vote électronique
je vais vous dire très franchement tous
les exemples ont montré que le vote
électronique ne garantissait pas
nécessairement l'indépendance du vote de
la personne dans mon esprit tendue au ps
de vote
c'est mon prénom mais attendez mais non
mettant toute façon ça n'empêche pas les
irrégularités mais moi je veux la
liberté de vote des gens 2 il faut qu'on
mette en place un système qui contrôle
tout le monde comme évidemment il ya des
risques de bourrages de ski à tous les
congrès de tous les partis c'est
tellement plus facile d'avoir un chef
qui décide comme emmanuel macron qui va
être le patron est qu après qu tous
béland youpi vive le chef
et ben non alors par ailleurs il faut
être hyper rigoureux dans le contrôle de
du vote
on a beaucoup progressé à ces votes ce
qui encore d'assez de permanents en
valeur dans ce cas la cia pu percer mais
c'est pas les permanents l'enquêté ce qu
il y aura beaucoup de votants est ce que
vous pensez qu'il aura foule là c'est
tout l'enjeu
oui c'est tout l'enjeu et je ne peux pas
vous dire ce que je pense d'être plus à
quelle heure cafouilleux plus on est
dans le match la mafia plus on est en
train de dire que c'est bourré d' avance
plus on est en train d'expliquer que
toute façon ça sert à rien il faut
redonner de la flamme pour donner de la
flamme il faut que ce soit des leaders
qui s'engage qui défendent leur point de
vue qui soit ouvert au point de vue des
autres et qu'on arrête cette espèce de
tout comme si tout le monde attendait
que ça se casse la figure
en croyant qu'il va récupérer je ne sais
quelle horrible merci redonner de la
flamme ce sera le mot de la fin marianne
en colère mais qui fait du bien autant
de merci beaucoup
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine cha
cha
[Musique]
le